this video is sponsored by the data
skills learning platform
data camp use the link in the
description to try the first chapter of
any course for free
lawrence worked his whole life for this
moment he had experienced
countless ups and downs endured days
weeks
months and sometimes even years of
continuous self-doubt
hardship sacrifice uncertainty and all
the rest
but now here he was finally tasting the
fruits of his labor
as they squeezed out from the very core
of his life
the day was august 12th 21 42
lawrence had just received a standing
ovation for a talk he gave at the
world's most popular
and respected biannual conference at
which
the greatest thinkers writers leaders
and innovators of all sorts
came both virtually or in person to give
one of their life's greatest
presentations
laying bare the accumulation of their
mind on a stage scrutinized by the
entire intellectual community
and general public at large the
conference was streamed and distributed
live across every virtual reality
augmented reality and general streaming
platform across the world
following his flawless talk both
lawrence and the audience
knew what they had just experienced a
beautiful and successful encapsulation
of a life's work that would likely
impact the way people thought
about human cognition values morality
and well-being forever
lawrence had spent the majority of his
adult life pursuing psychology
more specifically theoretical
neuropsychology
throughout his life he had this intense
compulsion to understand
with total and complete objectivity the
nature and state
of optimal well-being or rather what he
would go on to term
psychological worthiness the most
suitable ideal
social and personal conditions to
provide the individual with the greatest
subjective
qualitative conscious experience of
their life
he had spent the vast majority of his
20s and 30s experimenting
researching learning and failing
developing a variety of insights and
theories along the way
up until more recently now in his late
40s his work had mostly gone unnoticed
but for some inexplicable reason
lawrence always had this strange sense
that he was on the right track that
somehow everything was supposed to work
this way
he always felt a deep genuine connection
and enjoyment in his work
even when it would traditionally be
considered rather miserable
he also always seemed to find himself
falling into situations of great
unforeseen luck
just before hitting a wall or before
things got too bad or unmanageable
and now most importantly he was being
proven right
his work finally and actually clicking
into place bringing him right into that
destination
of limelight and giving him everything
he ever wanted
in this moment of the conference it felt
like he had truly touched the ultimate
state of life's worthiness
the very premise of his life's work
throughout the remaining three nights of
the conference following lawrence's talk
he was approached by a large number of
people both general and virtual
attendees
as well as other speakers they asked him
all sorts of questions
many attempted to rub his shoulder well
enough to become involved in his work
or get him involved in theirs women of
all sorts approached and hit on him
which he politely had to decline
pointing to his wife with him each time
and revealing a flawlessly attractive
woman who by all physical standards
was in an entirely other league he
entertained everyone as much as
necessary to remain polite
but mostly tried to get out of the
majority of the interactions as quick as
possible
one individual in particular however was
extremely interesting to lawrence
when he saw the man at the convention
center bar one of the nights
and recognized him as one of the first
speakers of the conference
lawrence actually hoped to get an
opportunity to speak with him
the man was mysterious with something
noticeably distinct and almost separate
about him
he fit the sort of super genius or
science fiction hero archetype
or perhaps super villain seemingly
always dressed in all black
with strange straight down hair an
unusual amount of bionic body
augmentations
and wearing all the latest technologies
almost like he was trying too hard to
fit in
but was a few decades too early this man
had given a similarly impactful talk
on a new groundbreaking brain computer
technology
two days prior to lawrence's talk
lawrence found it to be the most
ambitious
interesting and curious talk of the
entire conference so far
the man was essentially proposing and
announcing a soon-to-be publicly
available technology
which if it did what he said would
basically be the type of innovation
that defines and separates an entire
period of history
from all the prior he had termed the
technology
new life technology and was the founder
of the company being built around it
the company was set to basically offer
people the option to opt out of their
lives
after completely selecting defining and
more or less programming the conditions
of their desired experience of life
users would then step into cryogenic
chambers have electrodes implanted into
their brain
that would communicate brain signals
continuously stimulating neural
patterns and perceptual states and
ultimately simulating an entirely new
different life for the remainder of the
user's biological life
the machines would also nullify the
user's previous memories in the process
replacing them with newly encoded false
ones to match with their desired story
lines
experiences and conditions lastly
the user would be plugged into a
separate program connected to a quantum
supercomputer
that created populations of artificially
intelligent beings
who could then be interacted with within
the simulation in a manner that would be
arguably equivalent
to interacting with biological human
minds
previously in its slightly earlier forms
the technology had been used exclusively
for individuals with serious physical or
mental ailments
like body paralysis comas unresolvable
depression
trauma or worse in these cases it was
considered by most to be ethically
permissible
although for many even here it was still
certainly debatable
however it was federally approved in
most countries which was enough
now however this particular
neuroscientist and technologist premise
was to allow ordinary otherwise healthy
people
to use the technology this was met by
both worldwide support
and worldwide contempt the
understandably large
primary sticking point with the
technology was that it essentially
couldn't
at least not easily be reversed or
exited from
since once inside the user wouldn't know
that they were inside anything
and if it was set to be cut short the
effects of coming out could pose serious
mental risks
when trying to readjust back as a result
currently
users would essentially be required to
willingly and fully opt out of their own
life
until the end of their life part of what
the man was giving a talk about
was the risks compared to the benefits
of such a choice and how for some
if not many it would still for good
reasons
actually be the preferable option
lawrence found the entire premise of the
man's talk to be somewhere between
completely fascinating
and completely nonsensical in a lot of
ways
it contradicted his own talk and key
theories of well-being
and human values when the man approached
lawrence at the bar on the fourth night
of the conference
lawrence was excited to engage in a
discussion with him he had several
questions
criticisms and some hope that perhaps
the seeds of a potential collaboration
or debate could be planted for the
future the two congratulated each other
first
then discussed each other's talks for a
little while then moved on to other
broader philosophical topics
and then finally narrowed back in on the
new life technology
and its implications they started fairly
light-hearted but as a few more beers
were poured and emptied
the intensity increased lawrence argued
not about the ethics of what the man was
doing
but the philosophical problem with what
it presumed that consumers would and
should desire to leave their life
for a fake virtual one even if their own
life was relatively bad
and the new life could be anything they
wanted lawrence argued that people want
and should want to know and live in
reality
more than they want and should want to
live in what is purely pleasurable
easy desirable and designed to one's
preferences
we value the true form of things over
the mere pleasure of what things can
give us
the uncertainties and ups and downs of
life are important
essential even the negatives as much as
the positives
in most cases it's the difficulty
scariness and unpleasantness a part of
things
that allows the experience of things to
ultimately become meaningful or
worthwhile
or perhaps even capable of being
experienced at all lawrence said to the
man
the man had plenty of counter arguments
of course suggesting that if one felt
that life was best lived with ups and
downs
they could just program that in it need
not be pure pleasure lawrence
i don't disagree with you on that point
but that doesn't discredit the
technology
i'm not suggesting that people plug into
a purely blissful experience of life
if a purely blissful experience of life
is not desirable
but i am suggesting plugging into a
purely desirable life
the man replied yes but people still
want what is real
there are entirely separate factors
relevant to human experience beyond the
actual
feeling of experiences humans want to
earn their way to pleasure to
reward to meaning they want to be and do
within truth
even if it's painful or hard perhaps
even if it's only painful and hard with
no reward
if it's simply engineered chosen or
predetermined at the beginning
it's undesirable and most won't do it
and they shouldn't
lawrence went on with why not the man
asked with fairly sturdy confidence
aren't you merely assuming the position
that knowing truth will provide the most
desirable experience of life
or greatest well-being or whatever else
you called it i forget what term you
used in your work
in any case it isn't truth in it of
itself that you're actually arguing for
there
but the underlying desire for a
preferred state that truth will give you
worthiness lawrence quickly interjected
to confirm his preferred terminology
okay worthiness the man picked back up
let's assume that if that term
serves as an umbrella term for a life
maximized to its highest degree of
positive personal value
then it would not merely be a life
defined by the most pleasure or least
pain
nor the most truth or least illusion but
rather
the most optimal experience of life in
total regardless
sure lawrence interjected with hesitancy
then would not the difference between
life's maximal worthiness
and life's minimal worthiness only be a
matter of one's experience of it being
so
or perhaps more accurately the
experience of their believing it to be
yes but lawrence jumped in before
quickly being cut back
off and if so then any and all subset
qualities that maximize this condition
this state could all be set up to
perfection within our machines
concluded the man a little thrown off
now lawrence replied
without even having to look any further
into that argument i would still say
that you're missing the most important
part
it isn't real the people aren't real the
history and effects on the course of
reality are not real
none of it's real and that's fundamental
the man paused
nodded while smiling with clenched lips
and then asked lawrence with a
noticeable tinge of sarcasm
so then you don't want to do it lawrence
let out a small laugh while smiling
and rolling his eyes with a reciprocated
note of sarcasm
we could really use you the man added i
think a mind like yours could help us
both inside and outside
your ideas are really what's probably
missing i'm not supposed to share this
but we've already started short-term
trials where
people have gone in for short windows of
time and come back out just fine
i'd love to see if there was maybe an
opportunity there if you're ever
interested
look i don't personally see anything
ethically wrong with any of it
lawrence interrupted but i think you're
wrong to assume one
that people will want it and two that
they should be convinced that they do
i like this life it hasn't been easy but
it's real
so no i'm sorry but i'm gonna have to
pass
okay the man said with the final
accepting head nod
after a noticeably long pause of silence
between the two
the man turned back to lawrence and said
then would you like to exit this one
another shorter pause followed this the
bar
lawrence replied with a short confused
laugh underneath his words
the man turned more straight on towards
lawrence and took off his augmented
reality glasses
then he said lawrence you're going to
have to try to bear with me here
but you are currently in a new life
machine the man paused again to let
lawrence process the information and
reply
lawrence did not successfully do either
but could only laugh
believing with certainty that the man
was just joking or messing with him
i know this is hard the man went on with
it always is
but this right now is actually an exit
checkpoint inside a new life machine
you came up with the whole thing one of
the cleverest ones we've seen yet
i might add you essentially came up with
and scripted this entire conversation
as a method of gauging your own interest
in continuing or
leaving without revealing to yourself
that you're in anything
prior to you declaring to a bot myself
with sufficient certainty
that you are no longer interested in the
idea of being in here
and it seems to me that you just stated
that another brief pause hung between
them
you also planned on your own reasonable
skepticism here
so the man put his ar glasses back on
and swiped his hand a couple times in
relation to them
the entire bar all the other people
objects
everything turned pure white lawrence
began to sink into the truth of what was
happening
or rather sort of not happening if you
tell me that you would prefer to leave
this reality
which is in fact the simulation and
return to whom you were before in base
reality
i can send an alert signal that will
trigger a cease to the simulation right
now
but i'm the only one who can do this
lawrence and this is the only checkpoint
you currently have
you have a little time to think about it
right now but if you say no
i go away and this memory is erased and
that's almost certainly the end of any
way out
lawrence now petrified began to
noticeably and physically panic
the man grabbed lawrence by both his
shoulders and calmed him down once he
was calmed down enough
lawrence quickly asked what was before
the man looked through a display of vr
files only visible to him through his
glasses
then he said before was similar in the
overall fundamental sense
you were well sort of still are an
aspiring psychologist
especially interested in neuropsychology
but you were
are beginning to get somewhat old in
your mid hundreds now
you are still unsuccessful at least in
your view and lacking the intellectual
abilities to measure up to your dreams
of becoming a leading thinker
or theorist in this field you were alone
romantically in lower middle class
again that's all according to your own
self-approved report
lawrence looked down at his lap in
indescribable shock
then he looked back up why he admitted
the man motioned a quick swipe of his
hand again and then said
it was your dream to do what you did
here at this conference you wanted to be
a leading thinker
an important successful revolutionary
neuropsychologist
yeah a real one lawrence quickly
interjected
the man paused and looked more directly
at him you
are a real one another brief pause hung
in the air while lawrence tried to make
sense of this ridiculous seeming comment
many years ago you volunteered as an
early trial member to help develop this
technology
so far you've helped reveal and map
cognitive changes before
during and after and most importantly
provide real data and evidence on how to
best set up psychological and
neurological conditions
you're helping build a library of
reliable experiences in states
to be selected from for future users
your findings in here
are real they have and will help people
you know and don't know
remember and can't remember and lawrence
is there really any reason to believe
that an experience is less valuable
if it isn't real if one cannot know the
difference
another very long pause sat between the
two
so the man said would you like to stay
or leave
[Music]
this video was sponsored by datacamp
with data science data analytics and
data in general
increasingly becoming a central function
in material of the modern world
it is no secret that the demand and
opportunity for individuals with
creative
and analytical data skills is extremely
high
whether you want to learn more basic
simple things like spreadsheets or data
analysis with excel
or more advanced technical skills
related to becoming a data scientist
with r
data scientists with python a data
engineer data analyst
or basically any data path you can think
of data camp's online learning platform
has a massive library of over 300
courses and
interactive learning experiences that
cover nearly anyone's interests in
career tracks
perhaps one of the most unique and
useful aspects of data camps courses
is that you can learn not only without
needing any prior skills or
understanding
but also without needing any special
software as all courses can be completed
and practiced directly in the datacamp
platform with any regular internet
browser
if you're interested in pursuing or
learning more about what might go into
some form of future vr simulations or ai
type technologies
datacamp has several great courses
including ai fundamentals
and machine learning for everyone which
covered things like the broader terms
and concepts of ai and machine learning
as well as modeling in neural network
creation if you're interested by
clicking the link in the description
below
datacamp is offering the first chapter
of every course completely free
and once you find that you like the
platform a full unlimited access
subscription starts at just 25 dollars a
month
again if you're interested please click
the link in the description below
and give data camp a try for free and of
course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
you